j'ai rien contre nadal on fait des
petites dents sur michael jackson
mettez-moi trousses tribunal russe et
moi arrêtez moi aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on dirait on dirait look de gaga michael
jackson chanet on dirait l'oin jackson
j'adore mais quand un gars lui sans
déconner tu le prends comme ça on dira
candidats des chiffres et des lettres
avec la cravate et la truie oui alors
monsieur bouchard j'avais neuf lettres
j'avais flibustiers à jullié oui merci
allez vas-y fais nous plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
il restait longtemps la virilité la
version wii on a appelé lui sans rigoler
la foule mais j'aime bien c'est pas mal
ton gaffe premier degré de vous former
et toi tu étais persuadé qu'ils ne
concourraient pour le concours de
t-shirts mouillés coifferont verdès
concédantes
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour qu'il soit dans l'agitation
juive
je ne suis pas j'ai des règles très
précises et du sucre ont tous les quarts
d'heure c'est bien simple donc si tu la
joues th tout du sort il
je te le dis est ce calibre dont ces ils
risquent d'être agités mais il veut
toujours lui non alors non on va appeler
mamie jackson
[Applaudissements]
oui
je commence à danser
je voudrais remercier les élèves de 4e
de b du collège saint charles
cette année c'est la difficulté est là
elle encourt 2 mt merci merci merci
d'avancé et c'est vachement bien merci
c'est parti on est parti à lille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attendez elle va refaire la même dans ce
sens les électrodes
allez vas te cogner le nez des griffes
entendu elle a dit c'est pour toi
regardant dans les yeux on fera un jour
ses achats on sait pas s'il va lâcher
alors là là on est bien là on n'est plus
dans la course
l'ac thann autre animal et chantal à
merveille du monde elle a battu la
favela c'est un truc de fou là c'est un
animal qui n'existe pas encore va
secouer le cougar elle vous kiffe grave
est énorme et si ce garçon a tendu son
majeur depuis le début non mais t'as
quel âge les nids moi j'ai 17 ans bien
que j'avais seulement six fois bis et en
quoi tu vas te contenter de danser biais
non tu as tu eu ma chance et on attend
ta prestation avec un boyau
moi j'en habile à ces malades à aller
mieux avec
mais je danse avec kelly alors chacun
danse individuellement les règles sont
claires ça commence à danser les avec le
alors je te le dis tout de suite au bac
tu seras tout seul et on aimerait faire
une danse à deux il m'a alors excusez
moi alors on a balancé jackson n'a
jamais changé pas d'héberger les mecs
nous on est dans michael jackson aimait
classe est malade et c'est tu es là j'ai
eu très peur c'était d'emplir vous êtes
des fossés nabil alors je vais vous dire
j'en appelle aux autorités de ces vite
je vais appeler j'en appelle aux
autorités de ces huit franc capté dessus
nos gars on est devant un dilemme elle
vole danser à deux ce que je te propose
pointe si tu nous regardes je sais
qu'actuellement
tu regardes equidia parce que tu as pris
l'oseille soit la septième course à
longchamp
froch stock échange de chaîne et une on
regarde on va faire d'abord une danse
tout seul inquiète elle fera sa danse
mais on décidera avec le grand patron
franck happi louis signale donc ici
encore un appel à la clé un doublé de co
balance pour les amateurs de chimie on
verra ensuite c'est à dire on prend du
chlorure de sodium bien entendu et du
chlorure de potassium et on l'aimé on ce
qui nous donne un précipité qui noircit
à la lumière
[Applaudissements]
elle
les gars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la villa on ôte élèves noirs qui était
le meilleur danseur noël sans rigoler
elle est persuadée question mais quelle
à la soirée de l'année c'est genre là
elle est vraiment là même si un truc de
ouf la question mme salgado
mais chaque fois la même personne et qui
est ancienne et à la soirée de l'année
là mais tu es tu t'es cru donner la mort
alors est ce qu'on va voir kelly faire
sa pub jérôme actuelle ne soit pas signé
samassi c'est ce seul maillot national
de boutoir contre la juve à toulonnaise
parce que les gens te regardent oui ah
oui babillard pas mal de gens qui
commencent en avoir ras-le-bol de thé
non dans ce c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est un mythe qui sont maintenant
des meilleurs mais non mais non c'est
bravo donc non mais je sais pas danser
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est un coup de folie
amoureux alors je vous lis je viens
d'avoir un texto du patron vous irez
danser au moonlight c'est un bar sur
cergy pontoise
nous appelons à 19 heures ok merci le
christine kelly
ah non non non on les a lancé tu peux
danser genre moi cependant ce
journaliste je cours à la salle bien sûr
fait que demain il y aura le gros sous
terre et la danse on joue manille dans
son journal
vous mettez un petit peu de zhouqu a
refait pas de look c'est ma balle est
normal s'il vous plaît moi je suis pour
le fond que vous savez je ne travaille
pas vous mais je ne résout qu'est la
compagnie créole ou si je travaillais
pour souveraine en effet pendant des
années je vais vous dire je n'ai rien
contre cette danse vraiment j'adore le
son ça mais ok vous là il ay d'avancé
sur michael jackson la semaine prochaine
ou demain peut-être qu'on va regroupent
souvent comment je peux faire un appel
juste avant bien sûr à tous les membres
du cs 2 ap les bleus c'est sa danse et
on les embrasse va vous dire avec les
trois barques j'aurai d'autres
et sa bouteille de champagne crois que
la la le sexe alors qu'il est sûre avec
les bouteilles de champagne
oui c'était chaud tout le monde la sem
ap la nasa est en trompe pas de ces
zélés comme atom et douze bouteilles
frérot attentif là mais vous aime bien
la cesse je sais mais alors on est que
dresse le csa ils m'ont alors trouvait
bio téléspectateurs on est comme ça quoi
j'arrive dans des soirées par an on fait
du moule c'est ça mais aujourd'hui on
prend des bouteilles ensemble monsieur
schrameck vraiment in his et l'embrassa
on est comme ça
bon ça n'a pas fait une connerie de
l'année eh ben ça va peut-être commencer
ce soir sinon on parle et c'est sans
ballon
[Applaudissements]
beauté http jackson aeg peine ma carte
de presse ne savais pas du tout
journaliste ne danse pas bon allez les
moins chers et daniel bilalian ya déjà
des banques européennes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais si les mecs parce que j'ai vécu en
régie on leur dira tiens un viandard
écoute le truc qu'on a été lent à fond
alors bien entendu quand on est en
difficulté au niveau de la danse on
appelle une personne
cette personne nous a montré sur beyoncé
stand numéro un c'est vrai tu reviennes
farmer c'est le numéro un comme cela
fait du rené la taupe c'est également le
numéro sûr c'est quelqu'un qui dans ce
dernier l'autre exception avec son corps
avec son âme avec son coeur qui est avec
nous ce soir on a la chance de l'avoir
on l'appelle gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
tu traites une branche flash est clair
ouais on se tape très rapide merci je
vais faire e
excuse moi tu crois que tu vas faire
incendier m il est grave ce mec là les
attaques rapides
vous avez une musique rapide alors
je le connais un petit peu à la toupie
et koné
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention
c'est insupportable
il est habité à l'orée billets ou est
bienvenue d'habitude quand tu fais comme
tu le sens tu sais moi je fais des
soirées dans 500 ans
non sérieux samedi il ya partie du
jugement juste une minute
en mai 2008 le gars il est personnel qui
vient ici qu'on l'a trouvé
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont petits défauts
quoi la danse ça moi un petit peu chez
nass & wind auto qu'il évolue dans ce
pense aux téléspectateurs est rien les
téléspectateurs aiment http jackson
pense familiale une émission familiale
merci tu vas y tu fais ça sur mylène
farmer aussi un instrument parce que
michael jackson tu le disais du futur m
danse abacha s'appelle un style un site
en a pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire michael jackson j'ai
travaillé avec lui pendant des années je
peux dire que michael jackson quand je
lui disais tu es un petit peu soupe son
livre il m'écoutait away ont ensuite eu
ma mes côtés d'accord parce que moi tu
ça pour ton bien c'est parti mais à ce
que tu donnes après juste un truc à dire
ouais fais nous rêver
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
et ça michael m'a lancé tu m'a lancé